[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bonsoir bonsoir à toutes et à tous
Bienvenue c'est sens public du débat des
reportages des experts voilà le cocktail
qu'on vous propose tous les soirs à 18h
et 22h sur Public Sénat pour donner du
sens à l'actualité justement on commence
avec l'interview du chef de l'État hier
soir 1h10 d'émission pour rassurer les
Français donner un cap montrer qu'il
n'est pas un président affaibli a-t-il
réussi peut-il s'inventer une majorité
pour continuer de réformer ou sera-t-il
obligé de dissoudre rapidement
l'assemblée on en débat juste après ces
titres et puis dans la seconde partie de
l'émission notre semaine spéciale
consacrée au défi énergétiques le
secrétaire général de l'ONU rappelait ce
matin l'urgence climatique
avec la politique actuelle le monde se
dirige vers un réchauffement global de
2,8 degrés d'ici à la fin du siècle
dans cette course contre-la-montre que
peut-on espérer des énergies du futur
l'hydrogène la fusion que l'on teste à
Cadarache la bioluminescence la
recherche et le génie humain peuvent-ils
nous sauver ne ratez pas notre débat
tout à l'heure avec notamment deux
startups étonnantes
mais d'abord on voudrait voir tout de
suite le sujet de Fabien Ricard sur
l'actualité politique le président de la
République en première ligne on l'a pas
encore donc je vais les m’installer tout
simplement et je vais vous présenter mes
invités ça nous fera gagner peut-être
les quelques secondes nécessaires pour
que le reportage de Fabien soit dans la
machine claire Chartier bonsoir
bienvenue vous êtes journaliste et
essayiste j'accueille également
Jean-Daniel Lévy bonsoir bons directeur
délégué de l'institut Harris Interactive
France Bruno cotresses politologue
chercheur au CNRS et Laetitia cruppa
éditorialiste politique comme la vie et
bien faite le sujet de Fabien ricquerre
est prêt
alors que les conséquences de la guerre
en Ukraine et l'inflation pèsent sur le
quotidien des français Emmanuel Macron a
tenté de les rassurer tout en précisant
le cap de son quinquennat au fond nous
devons passer cette tempête c'est la
première chose que je leur dis et nous
allons la passer ensemble on en a pas
d'eau comme la crise covid et donc pour
traverser cette tempête on doit protéger
les plus faibles
nos étudiants nos familles les plus
modestes nos entreprises les plus
fragiles notre aussi notre industrie si
le chef de l'État refuse d'indexer les
salaires sur l'inflation il a annoncé
des mesures de soutien en collectivités
locales et aux entreprises frappées par
la hausse des prix de l'énergie et il a
ouvert la voie à un allongement de la
durée de cotisations sur les retraites
si certains sont prêts à s'engager à
dire nous on veut pas aller jusqu'à 65
ans mais par exemple on serait prêt à
aller jusqu'à 64 ans mais en
contrepartie si vous faites ce geste on
est prêt à travailler un peu plus de
trimestre parce qu'il y a une autre
façon de faire c'est pas que l'âge légal
c'est travailler un peu plus de
trimestre moi je suis ouvert et pour
avoir une majorité afin de faire passer
sa réforme Emmanuel Macron attendu la
main aux députés LR avant de dénoncer le
cynisme de la gauche au Parlement
coupable selon lui d'alliance des
extrêmes avec le RN après que ce dernier
avait soutenu la motion de censure
déposée par la nupes ils ont prouvé une
chose ils n'ont pas de majorité mais ils
ont surtout prouvé quoi que ils étaient
prêts socialistes écologiste communiste
et LFI à se mettre main dans la main
avec le rassemblement national alors
qu'il y a la guerre en Europe qu'il y a
la crise qu'elle désarroi de temps de
famille et qu'il nous faut être aux
côtés des Français indignation dans les
rangs de la nupesse où l'on renvoie au
président de la République la
responsabilité de la montée du RN tout
en dénonçant son appel du pied au LR
quand le président de la République a
ces mots c'est une blessure profonde
parce qu'il nous accuse de quelque chose
dont il est lui-même responsable
c'est-à-dire la montée du rassemblement
national et finalement le fait de mettre
dans un même bain les oppositions le
gouvernement pourrait également avoir
besoin du soutien DLR pour faire passer
ces textes sur l'immigration et les
énergies renouvelables en matière
d'environnement le chef de l'État a
appelé climat industrie et souveraineté
beaucoup de thèmes à aborder vous l'avez
vu et on réécoutera en reprendra
certaines extraits de
l'intervention et de l'interview du
présent Républic hier soir je vous
demandais peut-être une appréciation un
peu générale pour commencer claire
Chartier il voulait rassurer les
Français monter en quelque sorte montrer
en quelque sorte qu'il y avait un pilote
dans l'avion pour reprendre un cliché
est-ce qu'il a réussi d'après vous
je ne crois pas en fait parce que alors
le contexte est celui-ci c'est à dire
qu'il est en train de perdre pas mal de
points de popularité effectivement
beaucoup de gens s'interrogent sur sa
façon de gouverner ça aussi il a une
boussole ou pas et hier on a vu un
président de la République qui en fait
n'arrivait pas tellement à se départir
de son côté techno il a même un certain
moment vraiment plongé dedans la tête la
première où il était difficile de le
suivre donc sur les questions notamment
des batteries enfin et là ça devenait
vraiment très technique donc je ne suis
pas certaine que il est réussi vraiment
à emporter les gens et à les convaincre
qu'il faisait tout ce qu'il pouvait pour
lutter contre les difficultés
économiques qu'ils subissent aujourd'hui
notamment prenons l'exemple des
retraites ça m'a semblé assez
significatif sur les retraites
il a parlé à la fois me semble-t-il au
syndicat à la droite et finalement
des conseils s'ils sont pas tellement
retrouvés parce que d'un côté ils
disaient j'ai été élu sur un mandat
assez donc de repousser l'âge de départ
à la retraite à 65 ans et puis ensuite
il dit pour ouvrir en fait des
négociations éventuellement avec les
syndicats et aussi pour s'aligner
exactement sur la position LR il dit on
peut envisager l'hypothèse des 64 ans
sous conditions de rallonger les
cotisations
des trimestres de cotisations donc si
vous voulez je me demande comment les
Français s'ils sont retrouvés sur ce
point en particulier donc on avait
effectivement un exercice assez
finalement assez étrange Jean Daniel
Lévy on va parler des audiences après
parce qu'elles sont intéressantes à
analyser mais qu'est-ce sur le fond
qu'est-ce que vous retenez des messages
que le Président de la République a
voulu faire passer peut-être déjà il
suffit d'ouvrir la presse ce matin ou
d'écouter la radio et de se rendre
compte déjà que c'est pas les premiers
titres où en fait que ça fait pas
forcément la une des journaux alors même
qu'on est dans un climat où on a des
inquiétudes concernant certes le pouvoir
d'achat mais également les thématiques
écologiques et environnementales voire
la crise la crise ukrainienne et que
globalement on retient essentiellement
en tout cas ce qu'on entend ce matin
lorsqu'on a pas assisté à l'émission
essentiellement le positionnement qu'il
a pu avoir à l'égard de la nuque
concernant le fait qu'il se soit accepté
cette colère d'accepter en fait les voix
du rassemblement national mais il y
avait plein d'autres messages qui
étaient émis il y avait des messages
subliminaux qui avaient des messages qui
étaient un peu plus implicit mais que
aujourd'hui ce matin en fait 12 heures
après en fait l'interview du président
de la République c'est plus en fait une
positionnement tactique de ce qui se
passe à la salle nationale qui est
réévoquée plutôt que d’ailleurs le fond
politique sur les processus de
réassurance auxquels il était appelé et
ce qui est assez intéressant vous avez
fait un tout petit lapsus si vous savez
vous êtes repris l'intervention et après
vous avez dit l'interview du président
mais je crois qu'en plus c'est tout à
fait révélateur d'ailleurs de la nature
de l'émission d'hier parce qu'à un
moment on se demandait est-ce qu'il
s'agit d'une interview ou est-ce qu'il
s'agit d'une intervention de la part du
président de la République parce
[Musique]
la vieille quelque part on dit que le
pouvoir abîme beaucoup c'est vrai et au
sens que cette Vista cette vitalité
qu'il incarnait tellement en 2017
ce jeune homme de 39 ans élu à la
présence de la République première
élection à laquelle il se présente c'est
il gagne le gros lot c'est le siège de
numéro 1 du pays balade un seul coup
hier on le sent un peu un peu en panne
il réutilise des mots qu'on l'entend
utiliser depuis très longtemps
maintenant le sentiment qu'on tourne un
petit peu en rond autour des
problématiques il a des des boucles
comme ça d'arguments qui reviennent très
fréquemment d'une interview à l'autre et
de la difficulté pour lui de se
renouveler alors que lui-même a incarné
tellement le renouvellement c'est
vraiment intéressant sur l'audience
Jean-Daniel Lévy je reviens vers vous
c'est plutôt un flop on peut dire ça oui
quand on regarde et même surprenament on
peut dire qu'il y a un peu plus de 4
millions de téléspectateurs qui ont
regardé hier l'intervention des
d'Emmanuel Macron ou l'interview
d'Emmanuel Macron il était même
faites par le passé et là hier on se
demandait va-t-il y avoir ou pas
indexation des salaires sur l'inflation
va-t-il y avoir en fait des mesures
précises concernant l'énergie etc donc
peut-être des dimensions qui justement
sentir une attente non plus de alors
dans les jours qui ont précédé il y
avait aussi des équipes féministes sont
pas su la faire monter il y avait ça et
deux il y avait effectivement peut-être
cette dimension de teasing entre
guillemets en très bon français qui
était moins présente il faut se rappeler
peut-être que en général on le savait
uniquement deux trois jours avant qu'il
y avait intervention de la part du
président applique on en parlait on se
demandait et donc il y avait un moment
concentré de tension là ça fait
pratiquement trois semaines qu'on sait
que le président réplique va parler
aujourd'hui donc effectivement une forme
de dramaturgie qui était un peu moins
importante mais qui est présente non
seulement en amont mais également en
fait en aval ou aujourd'hui en fait on
voit bien que on en parle ici très bien
tout à l'heure
avec vous on est en pleine vacances
scolaires donc déjà la programmation de
France 2 pour moi a été assez étrange on
commence déjà par ça c'est à dire que
c'est elle est validé par les Lisée mais
on est en pleine vacances scolaires
enfin moi justement je me suis dit il va
y avoir personne quoi va y avoir 200000
c'est honnêtement 4 millions et il est
devant tous les autres à cette heure-là
donc bon bah il est premier 18 18 % de
marché d'audience bon c'est pas c'est
pas non plus ridicule non honnêtement
moi je trouve que c'est pas si c'était
pas ridicule et c'est effectivement
moins bien si on compare avec l'émission
après voilà c'est pas les vacances et
quant au message apparemment selon mes
sources dans les coulisses même c'est
très proche conseillé et pas vraiment au
courant des messages qu'il allait faire
passer hier soir voyez-vous donc je
pense qu'elle a eu un problème de soit
de communication entre eux soit un petit
manque de de préparation ou soit pas
vraiment de messages c'est que je pense
qu'en fait l'objectif hier ça n'était
pas forcément d'annoncer mais
d'expliquer en fait tout ce qui se fait
parce que visiblement moi il y a quelque
chose qui me frappe on peut considérer
que le parti pris d'Emmanuel Macron
vraiment très pro entreprises le fait
passer parfois à côté des demandes très
fortes de la sensibilité en tout cas
dans la société pour plus de
redistribution etc mais il y a quand
même une forme une forme de d'un
gratitude dans la société aujourd'hui
vis-à-vis parce que Emmanuel Macron
disait hier mettez en exergue ce qu'il a
fait le chômage par exemple on a quand
même le chômage a quand même baissé
c'est un cancer français le chômage en
Alain tant parler pendant si longtemps
et aujourd'hui on en parle à peine
le reconnaître enfin je ne fais pas là à
la défense d'emmel Macron mais
simplement il est évident que nous avons
moins d'inflation que les autres pays
européens donc tout ça ce sont des
éléments qui apparaissent comme des
arguments de vente politique et ils le
sont évidemment d'un certain côté mais
ça n'est pas que ça c'est à dire que à
tout lire au prisme de du calcul
politique et de la lecture politique
finalement on en vient à oublier réalité
concrète sur laquelle on peut s'appuyer
pour repartir et je pense que c'est ça
qu'il tentait de faire hier de façon
parfois habile à mon sens lorsqu'il a
sorti ses schémas moi je trouve que
c'était assez éclairant là en l'espace
après malabile lorsqu'il se perdent en
des détails techniques mais à mon avis
l'objet c'était celui-là pour essayer de
contrer cette forme d'ingratitude et là
contre laquelle en fait il ne peut pas
faire grand chose il y a une forme je
trouve une fois de tragique
en ce moment c'est clair qu'il y avait
un moi je l'ai trouvé paradoxal hier à
la fois le contenu en fait est assez
riche c'est vrai il annonce pas grand
chose mais le contenu est assez riche
quand on y prête beaucoup attention il y
a énormément d'informations qui sont
données d'explication il y a une mise en
perspective qui essaye de faire
notamment au tout début de l'émission où
là il est assez à l'aise je trouve pour
pour expliquer en particulier sur la
question du pouvoir d'achat de
l'inflation
et en même temps effectivement on voit
qu'il y a des moments donnés où il est
quand même face à un mur de difficultés
et j'ai trouvé très symptomatique de ce
point de vue là sa réaction après ce
cours reportage qui interview un couple
qui gagne 4000 euros par mois alors il
se trouve que ce couple il habite à
neauphle-saint-martin dans l'Eure une
commune dans la circonscription a donné
un député rassemblement national qui a
bombardé Marine Le Pen à 34% premier
tour à 55% au deuxième tour dans cette
commune effectivement l'envoie le chef
de l'État qui part dans un raisonnement
à ce moment-là ces technocratique et des
millions mais non on fait des choses on
a on a créé des emplois tout ça mais il
ne répond pas à la question essentielle
c'est à dire tous quand nous entendons
qu'une famille en France sur 4000 euros
par mois et ne peut pas devenir
propriétaire tout le monde tombe des
nuits
qu'on lui a entendu à propos de la nuque
mieux utiliser à ce moment là et
d'ailleurs il était au courant de ce
reportage comme vous l'avez dit c'est
préparé et du côté France 2 On a été
aussi surpris qu'il ne s'engage pas dans
ce boulevard parce que il savait que
pour lui c'était l'occasion de montrer
son empathie et de se rapprocher des
Français et il a complètement est
complètement passé à côté alors ce que
je retiens c'est quand même un petit
côté un peu trop techno ou
technique ou technocratique dans vos
différentes interventions c'est aussi ce
que nous disait ce matin le député
Europe Écologie Les Verts sur France
Inter Yannick Jadot en écoute j'ai
trouvé le président détaché pas concerné
par les difficultés des Françaises et
des Français par ce qui se passe dans
notre pays par les chocs climatiques il
y a 15 jours dans son émission sur les
affaires
internationales on avait un président on
est d'accord on n'est pas d'accord mais
on sentait intéressé
curieux engagé là c'est un président qui
la prochaine émission il va nous sortir
des feuilles Excel je veux dire c'était
barbant que c'était ennuyeux et puis
surtout pour celles et ceux qui
pensaient encore
pouvoir élu Mendès sous Rocard ils ont
l'arrogance de Giscard la brutalité de
Sarkozy l'arrogance de Giscard la
brutalité de Sarkozy Laetitia vous avez
une autre référence en tête un autre
face à face entre un journaliste et un
président de la République c'est pas moi
c'est l'Élysée qui a ce précédent en
tête Emmanuel Macron depuis sa campagne
présidentielle il a le Mitterrand 88 en
tête et toute son équipe là donc il s'en
inspire beaucoup et c'est vrai que c'est
face à face sur un plateau de télévision
entre 1 ou une journaliste et un
président en exercice en fait sont très
rares donc c'est vrai qu'il y a eu un
précédent j'ai cherché un peu dans
l'histoire de la 5e République et il y a
celui de Yves Mourousi et de François
Mitterrand qui à l'époque avait
complètement cartonné vous savez on le
connaît tous c'est le moment où il dit
vous êtes chez brand non on dit câblé
aujourd'hui enfin c'est devenu carrément
cultes
négligemment assis sur le bord de la
table sur planbon le président
République c'est une audace dingue pour
l'époque quoi disruptif on dirait
aujourd'hui et ils avaient fait trois
numéros en fait parce que effectivement
l'audience était très bonne et pourquoi
en fait Jacques Pilon qui était le spin
doctor
le conseiller en communication de
Mitterrand lui avait conseillé de faire
ça alors que Mitterrand à la télévision
c'était pas trop son truc parce que il
était justement en chute de notoriété et
que son image était vraiment écornée
donc il fallait reprendre un lien avec
avec les Français et regagnant en
popularité en popularité oui parce que
d'une certaine manière c'est un peu
l'impasse dans laquelle se trouve
aujourd'hui Emmanuel Macron donc les
lycées pas confirmé directement c'est
vrai que ça a été un peu du
copier-coller mais quand même ils ont
regardé ces émissions avec Yves Mourousi
et c'est une grande source d'inspiration
vous savez Thomas en communication
politique on regarde souvent dans le
rétroviseur et le parallèle il est
d'autant plus légitime que la tal alors
la troisième interview movie Mitterrand
diffusé le 2 mars 86 on est tout proche
des position législatives alors là on
est après chez nous mais juste avant la
cohabitation pourquoi vous trouvez ça
intéressant et je trouve ça intéressant
parce que en fait on sent que le
Mitterrand est fragilisé et d'ailleurs
il va perdre et il y aura une
cohabitation et j'ai juste relevé une
phrase de François Mitterrand qui
demande aux Français en fait de ne pas
être injuste avec la majorité sortante
et que sinon s'il perd ce sera une
majorité de combat contre le président
qu'il y aura du désordre ça c'est un mot
qu'on a entendu chez Emmanuel Macron
hier soir et il dit François Mitterrand
une période difficile alors que les
Français veulent une certaine Concorde
donc c'est vrai que c'est un peu la
situation dans laquelle Emmanuel Macron
et sa sortie sur l'accord l'alliance
entre la nuque et le RN fait penser
aussi à cette à cette allusion François
Mitterrand et donc pour conclure on y
revient une tentative de du présent
République pour à la fois retrouver de
la popularité et asseoir son pouvoir
ouais on est clairement dans une
stratégie pensée élaborer de
communication de de la part de l'Elysée
et ces deux émissions de France 2 sont
inscrites dans cette stratégie déjà
représentualisée Emmanuel Macron le
régime qui a tendance à être finalement
effacé par les tumultes de l'Assemblée
nationale et puis peut-être on n'en sait
rien mais préparer une future
dissolution donc c'est vrai que Emmanuel
Macron reprend là en tout cas pour ces
deux émissions de France 2 sa position
jupitérienne alors ça ouvre un chapitre
qu'on pourrait intitulé Nupe dissolution
et cohabitation en quelque sorte Bruno
cotresses est-ce que
c'est on se base c'est cohabitation
c'est les deux septennats de François
Mitterrand il faut s'en souvenir ils ont
l'un et l'autre marqué par une était
marqué par une cohabitation est-ce que
c'est le destin qui attend le président
français actuel
pas nécessairement non pas
nécessairement il faut il faut se
rappeler qu'à l'époque on a des
cohabitations parce que les élections
législatives ont décalées
d'une certaine manière et donc elle
favorise aussi l'expression de vote
sanction pour faire passer un message
donc là on est dans quelque chose qui
est qui est différent on a senti
effectivement hier le chef de l'État
curieusement peut-être être lui en
position de demandeurs ce qui n'est pas
très bon
il a abattu une carte très importante
hier il s'est mis en position de
demandeurs par rapport aux républicains
en disant oui je suis effectivement
favorable à une alliance il a hésité en
disant une alliance sur certains
dossiers puis après il a plutôt dit une
alliance voilà carrément donc moi j'ai
trouvé qui se mettait un peu en position
de demandeur et c'est vrai que
aujourd'hui s'il devait organiser des
élections anticipées il y a peut-être un
peu de soucis à se faire pour lui il y a
deux paramètres très importants en
matière d'élection anticipée l'État
économie il y a certains dimensions qui
vont bien mais globalement le contexte
est perçu comme en contexte et la
popularité s'était rappelé tout à
l'heure la popularité qui est en berne
pour le moment elle était en eau tiède
elle commence à se fragiliser la
première ministre a perdu pas mal en
popularité elle n'arrive pas bien à
imprimer sa propre marque de fabrique
dans l'opinion donc il y a des éléments
de fragilités importants pour celui qui
serait tenté d'appuyer sur le bouton
dissolution Jean-Daniel Lévy le prénom
République il a surtout parlé à la
droite et où elle est derrière
clairement là pour le coup en fait si
les Français n'ont pas entendu le
message je suis persuadé que les 62
députés LR ont entendu 100% le message
qui était adressé non seulement en fait
concernant le positionnement non
seulement effectivement comme il a
indiqué que il avait besoin d'aller
chercher à créer des alliances et que
celle-ci en fait ne s'était pas produite
mais également quand en fait on regarde
les termes qui l'utilisent en fait il
parle de sécurité il parle de
reconnaissance de la valeur travail il
parle de liberté il parle d'engagement
il parle de responsabilité dans là c'est
mieux logique qu'on peut avoir ce sont
des termes qui parlent beaucoup plus de
manière un peu caricaturale à la droite
qu'à la gauche et on voit bien même à la
fin de son intervention lorsqu'il est
question de du rapport entre immigration
et sécurité lorsqu'il est lancé dessus
et notamment par Caroline Roux il hésite
un petit peu et puis à la fin sans dire
qu'il l'effectue un lien absolu il dit
que à Paris il constate effectivement en
fait que de très nombreux en fait cas de
lié à la sécurité sont liés à des
personnes qui sont d'origine d'origine
étrangère donc il y a un pas
supplémentaire qui je me trompe pas a
été effectué sa part et qu'il n'avait
pas été dit ou en tout cas verbaliser de
la part de l'exécutif et quand on voit
aujourd'hui les prises de position
si ce n'est du ration nationale en tout
cas des personnes qui sont proches des
républicains c'est effectivement en fait
des liens qui ont tendance à être
effectués de plus en plus d'un point de
vue d'opinion alors justement il
s'adresse aux députés LR également
fondateur et l'air et je propose à
Audrey betas de nous rejoindre tout de
suite bonsoir Audrey bienvenue
heureusement que vous êtes là parce que
cette émission que deviendrait-elle sans
vous faut les reportages et les
chroniques depuis deux jours merci en
tout cas comment a réagi la majorité de
droite au Sénat et ben autant vous dire
qu'au Sénat on ne se bouscule pas pour
tant pour saisir pardon la main tendue
d'Emmanuel Macron le chef de l'État vous
l'avez dit pourtant égrainer hier les
sujets qui parlent à la droite avec une
nouvelle loi sur l'immigration il remet
aussi la réforme des retraites sur la
table mais pour Bruno Retailleau le
patron des républicains au Sénat ce ne
sont que des mots il dit même du
président qu'il est un homme de coach
avec des dépenses publiques incontrôlées
on l'écoute ça fait des mois et des mois
qui l'a fait la danse du ventre et on a
bien vu que le groupe LR à l'Assemblée
nationale avait résisté et moi si je me
suis lancé dans la candidature à la
présidence de LR c'est pas pour avoir
l'ambition de faire de LR la énième
compos de la macronie nous ne sommes pas
macro-compatibles officiellement parmi
LR personne n'est dupe on dénonce même
un coût politique du président que la
sénatrice Jacqueline au salbrignaud a
très peu apprécié au moment où les
Français vont mal nous sommes en pleine
crise des énergies a-t-elle rappelée
elle a eu des mots très forts à son
encontre il est machiavélique voilà
voilà il y a un côté machiavélique et il
se fout de nous vraiment vraiment et je
pense que ce qui est inquiétant c'est
que je ne suis pas sûr que les Français
vont me supporter comme ça pendant cinq
ans tu sais moi je fais la petite depuis
longtemps j'ai eu j'ai entendu des
présidents qui avaient des personnes
disaient très différentes de droites
comme de gauche mais il parlait aux
Français là il parlait pas aux Français
il parlait un conseil d'administration
et ça c'est inquiétant
parmi ces sénateurs et sénatricellers
qui sont moins catégoriques oui il y a
ceux qui n'ont pas été convaincus par
l'interview hier pardon mais qui demande
à voir après tout sans majorité le
président va avoir besoin des LR pour
faire passer certains textes alors
pourquoi ne pas en profiter sur la
réforme des retraites par exemple qui
est l'air compatible Philippe mouillé et
de ceux qui attendent des gages
c'est un signe fort mais de nouveau
beaucoup de prudence nous attendons de
voir quel sera le contenu de cette
réforme des retraites il y a eu quelques
annonces qui vont plutôt globalement
dans notre sens on pense que c'est une
priorité de pas le calendrier et la
situation de la France mais de nouveau
nous avons tellement une habitude des
effets d'annonce que nous avons besoin
d'avoir des preuves concrètes d'une
vraie volonté devoir travailler sur un
sujet qui forcément et bien nous
satisfait
un discours présidentiel ne suffit pas
Mathilde nous attendons des éléments
tangibles pour voter ce texte pour voter
ce texte la porte n'est pas totalement
fermée merci beaucoup Audrey Chartier là
on est en pleine élection interne chez
LR et il faut peut-être
intégrer cette temporalité c'est-à-dire
que qu'est-ce qui peut se passer après
l'élection est-ce que est-ce que cette
main tendue peut devenir beaucoup plus
séduisante pour le parti
Jean-François Copé l'incarnait tout à
fait il y avait vraiment une ligne et
une volonté chez certains minoritaire
certes de jouer l'alliance avec avec
Emmanuel Macron Renaissance il faut
quand même rappeler le piètre état de LR
parce que lorsqu'on les entend on a
l'impression que il représente une force
flamboyante ils sont quand même peu
nombreux s'il y avait une dissolution
ici ils sont puissants
s'il y avait une dissolution quand même
un certain nombre de députés
ne serait pas forcément réélu donc il
marche quand même sur un fil on n'a pas
du tout l'impression lorsqu'on entend
ses interventions donc c'est de bonne
guerre de faire monter les enchères
enfin je veux dire qu'il est c'est tout
à fait normal ça serait même curieux qui
ne le fasse pas cette manière mais
lorsqu'il parle des retraites par
exemple je l'évoquais tout à l'heure
quand même ce qui a évoqué Emmanuel
Macron hier c'est c'est quand même
pratiquement facile même la même chose
que ce que j'ai entendu dire dans la
bouche de Browner et taillot face à leur
en berger la veille donc c'est quand
même une
sorte d'ambiguïté mais qui relève là
vraiment je pense de la dramaturgie
politique ils ont enfin moi j'exclut pas
du tout que y ait effectivement un
rapprochement entre LR et
la majorité
Bruno cauteresse la dissolution on l'a
pas encore évoqué en détail dans ce dans
ce débat c'est clairement une des cartes
voilà dans le dans le jeu de pouvoir
d'un président de la République sous la
sous la 5e et est-ce que c'est une
obligation depuis plusieurs jours on
entend tous cette petite musique de du
il pourra pas faire autrement le
président va dissoudre l'Assemblée
qu'est-ce que vous en pensez ah c'est
pas une obligation d'ailleurs lui-même
hier soir a dit que il n'entendait pas
se lier les mains donc il a essayé de
poser un démenti à ce qui était dit que
le chef d'État aurait dit si un vote
motion de censure jeudi soir non non il
est pas obligé il pourrait très bien s'y
prenait contre lui une motion de censure
essayez de nommer un nouveau Premier
ministre qui lui pourrait avoir un vote
d'un sentiment peut-être même de trouver
une personnalité qui soit une
personnalité témoin identifiée Macron
que l'actuel première ministre mais
c'est vrai que politiquement par contre
la situation devient difficile à ce
moment-là votre de censure ou sur de
censure c'est quand même très infamant
pour l'exécutif ça m'a quand même dire
des choses extrêmement importantes un
message d'affaiblissement extrêmement
lourd pour l'exécutif et c'est vrai que
si on prend la perspective et le point
de vue du bon fonctionnement du système
démocratique c'est vrai que ça pose de
plein pied la question de dire il faut
peut-être reposer la question aux
Français et c'est vrai que que lui hier
tout en disant qu'il avait d'autres
ressources constitutionnelles il a pas
non plus dit qu'il s'en servirait pas
alors c'est vrai que c'est une arme qui
depuis la dissolution entre guillemets
ratée de 1997 et mauvaise réputation on
hésite beaucoup à s'en servir il faut
toujours appeler que c'est un 21 avril
que Jacques Chirac avait annoncé la
dissolution donc il y avait un deuxième
21 avril douloureux en France de ce
point de vue là et c'est vrai que le
président peut peut-être hésiter on ne
saurait pas bien j'imagine que les les
sondeurs ont des choses sans doute à
dire sur ces questions il est trop tôt
pour se poser ce type de questions mais
on n'imagine pas très bien aujourd'hui
que qu'est-ce qui pourrait sortir d'une
élection d'une élection anticipée c'est
un signe de faiblesse important pour
l'exécutif s'il en est conduit à
ça en même temps
c'est vrai qu'on a vu aux élections
législatives que certaines formations
politiques étaient arrivés à en c'est
quelque chose du côté de la nuque mais
on a vu depuis que c'était aussi un peu
compliqué donc voilà c'est c'est très
difficile aujourd'hui de savoir
qu'est-ce qui sortirait d'élection
législative anticipée alors on écoute
une autre réaction on avait on avait
rien que j'adore tout à l'heure je
voudrais qu'on écoute ensemble celle du
secrétaire général de la CGT Philippe
Martinez vous l'évoquez tout à l'heure
claire Chartier depuis on peut même
remonter à la crise covid depuis deux
ans et demi l'État a dépensé des
dizaines voire des centaines de
milliards au soutiens des ménages des
entreprises des Français en général pour
Philippe Martinez ça suffit pas vous
avez noté que même avec le bouclier
l'énergie augmente de 15%, c'est-à-dire
deux fois plus le SMIC et puis il doit
pas les faire ses courses souvent parce
que si on prend les produits les
produits première nécessité il y a une
enquête de 30 millions de consommateurs
vous prenez le prix des pâtes tu vas
pouvoir manger ils ont pas mis le foie
gras mais en tout cas les pâtes la
farine la viande les fruits c'est plutôt
alimentation à deux chiffres que un seul
chiffre donc il est complètement hors
sol et il a fait de l'auto-satisfaction
comme il avait dit qu'il arrêterait de
faire
Chartier en entendant ça je me suis dit
la démo écologie n'est pas réservé aux
hommes politiques bref on peut on peut
aller plus loin dans l'analyse oui non
mais enfin c'est un petit peu la
réaction que j'ai aussi c'est à dire que
on voit bien quand même un exécutif qui
tente de se démener d'ailleurs c'est
bien pour ça que il a aussi beaucoup de
critiques de ce côté là comme quoi il
serait trop dépensier et que comment
va-t-on faire face à une dette qui qui
enfle et d'ailleurs ça lui cause pardon
nous interrompre des soucis de de
force de sa propre majorité parce que le
discours de d'horizon et d'Édouard
Philippe c'est ça donc on dit que sa
majorité fragile elle l'est aussi sur
cette question c'est un autre point
qu'on n'a pas évoqué mais c'est vrai
qu'on quand même on voit un exécutif qui
se démène pour essayer de tenir les deux
bouts c'est à dire une certaine forme de
comment dire de rigueur économique et
puis en même temps de répondre à
l'urgence sociale et puis derrière c'est
pour ça que tout à l'heure j'employais
un peu le enfin il y a une forme de
tragédie aussi là dedans c'est que on a
on a l'impression que les Français d'un
côté on le sait n'aime pas l'emprise de
l'État et puis la situation est
tellement tendue aujourd'hui qu'ils ont
demandé toujours plus à l'état un peu
comme si un peu comme au marabout qui
aurait toutes les réponses en fait et
c'est vrai que face à ça face à cette
demande enfin moi je n'aimerais pas à la
pratique très personnel être à la place
d'Emmanuel Macron parce que c'est une
demande impossible à satisfaire quelque
part donc c'est vrai qu'on peut toujours
dire que c'est compliqué on peut
toujours dire que les difficultés
quotidiennes et elles le sont s'accentue
ça mon cell mais soyons quand même un
peu honnête Emmanuel Macron n'a rien à
voir avec la guerre en Ukraine ou
l'inflation qui a des sources exogènes
et qui donc à laquelle il faut bien
répondre avec les moyens qu'il a donc il
y a oui une forme de démagogie à côté
stable
bien sûr l'inflation elle est mieux
contenue en France que dans les autres
pays
[Musique]
en fait localement parfois augmentation
pour ceux qui sont propriétaires de la
taxe foncière il y a eu parfois
l'augmentation d'un système de produits
de services locaux en fait qui troublent
un peu un peu le message mais on peut
même remonter à quelques années
précédemment en fait Bruno cotresses il
me faisait implicitement référence que a
supprimé la vignette qui était
considérée comme étant une forme de taxe
sur les automobilistes qui à l'origine
était fléchés comme on dit aujourd'hui
vers les personnes âgées c'était plus le
cas il espérait où il souhaitait en fait
qu'il puisse y avoir au final un
bénéfice électoral on a vu qu'il n'a pas
été tout à fait à la hauteur de ce qu'il
pouvait de ce qu'il pouvait escompter
donc on a deux dimensions en fait il y a
une dimension objective et une dimension
subjective les dimensions objectives les
Français voient bien que la situation
n'est pas exactement la même en France
qu'au niveau européen il voit bien en
fait et les tableaux en fait globalement
leur permet ça n'est pas en général on
leur dit on leur dit on sait quelle est
la différence vis-à-vis des messages
officiels donc c'est ça globalement
c'est relativement entendu d'accord
est-ce que c'est écouter pas non plus
donc c'est à dire qu'en fait on va avoir
tendance à dire oui très bien mais on
reste la France et ça après on revient à
sa propre situation plus éventuellement
à des questions de justice sociale ou
justice fiscale c'est pas sans raison
que en France par rapport à d'autres
pays on a eu le débat soit l'ISF qui est
revenu on a eu le débat en fait sur la
taxation en fait des super profits qui
étaient présentes en fait où il y a une
focalisation extrêmement forte sur les
salaires des grands patrons on a pu le
voir par exemple à l'égard de Total qui
sont des débats si je me trompe pas qui
ont eu lieu en France mais qui ont pas
eu lieu en tout cas avec cette intensité
dans les autres pays européens et là on
revient à un regard qui est porté à
l'égard d'Emmanuel Macron mais qui est
pas récent mais qui est un regard ancien
c'est président des riches et ça lui
colle de manière un peu peur
de Philippe Martin et qui revient et
donc en fait malheureusement pour lui
aujourd'hui quoi qu'ils disent quoi
qu'il fasse quel que soit ses
orientations il va avoir
une petite perception que d'une manière
ou d'une autre il est plutôt du côté de
ceux qui sont en haut et de ceux qui
réussissent comme il l'a dit plutôt qui
se sentent social je sais pas ce que
vous en pensez sur le dividende salarié
parce que les dividendes salariés ça
c'est une mesure de justice sociale et
je trouve que ça a été escamoté dans le
débat et or c'est très important
de ce de ce point de vue là
qu'effectivement ce sont des annonces
qui ne sont pas captées ça n'imprime pas
hier il a essayé de jouer à de
nombreuses reprises le en même temps
macronien on était totalement dedans
hier je reprends ces mots il faut
travailler plus longtemps mais pour
vivre dignement des frais de centrale il
faut faire davantage des forts mais il
faut que effectivement il y a des
dividendes qui soient mieux répartis et
nous ici c'est ça le vrai dialogue
social il a utilisé beaucoup hier la
notion de partager la valeur ajoutée
c'est presque du vocabulaire
d'économistes assez à gauche en fait
l'idée de partager la valeur ajouter
qu'elle est pas bien répartie qu'elle
est pas bien partagée après donc il a
essayé de multiples reprises d'incarner
son en même temps et de gauche et de
droite parce qu'on capte surtout c'est
il faut travailler davantage les temps
sont durs il va falloir bosser davantage
faire plus des faire plus d'efforts
alors qu'il a essayé de multiples
reprises hier soir de nous vendre à
nouveau son en même temps c'est
l'hémisphère droit qui a pris plus clair
précisément je pense que ce qui dessert
beaucoup Emmanuel Macron c'est son
incapacité parfois à déployer des
messages qui sont au cœur en fait de son
action parce que justement évoquait le
travail la valeur travail qui a priori
est une valeur bon assez logique il faut
produire pour pourquoi qui est de la
croissance et que le pays prospère c'est
assez consensuel aussi et finalement
c'est aussi au cœur de la philosophie
libérale c'est-à-dire que c'est par le
travail qu'on s'émancipe que l'individu
peut avancer or qu'est-ce qui se passe
hier et donc il a évoqué cette
Sandrine Rousseau c'est vrai que ce
discours il est assez limite parce que
l'émancipation par le travail lorsque on
travaille justement
dans le travail jusque là avec un
salaire très médiocre et puis parfois
pas de protection sociale et bien ça
contredit forcément l'idéal mais ce qui
ce qui n'arrive pas à faire c'est que
hier par exemple il a évoqué donc cette
cette question là en disant qu'ils
allaient discuter des conditions de
travail dans le domaine de la santé les
infirmières les médecins mais on les
écoutant on a eu l'impression qu'il
allait s'agir de mesures techniques et
que ça ne s'insérait pas du tout dans
une réflexion plus globale plus
matricielle sur ce que représente le
travail dans sa perspective à lui c'est
à dire dans la dans la tradition
libérale que je viens d'évoquer il
aurait pu le replacer là-dedans et ça
aurait donné une colonne vertébrale ça
lui aurait donné un récit donc une pâte
une matière ce qui semble complètement
lui faire défaut aujourd'hui et qui donc
peut-être pourrait un peu contrecarrer
cette impression de flottement et de
conserve on va rester finalement sur les
thématiques économiques et sociales
puisque le dernier thème que je voudrais
qu'on aborde nous reste à peu près 7
minutes dans ce débat c'est le thème des
des retraites et donc je vous propose de
réécouter
un extrait de l'interview d'Emmanuel
Macron hier soir sur France 2 face à
Caroline Roux le thème des retraites
si certains sont prêts à s'engager à
dire nous on veut pas aller jusqu'à 65
ans mais par exemple on serait prêt à
aller jusqu'à 64 ans mais en
contrepartie si vous faites ce geste on
est prêt à travailler un peu plus de
trimestre parce qu'il y a une autre
façon de faire c'est pas que l'âge légal
c'est travailler un peu plus de
trimestre moi je suis ouvert le tout
c'est que notre modèle
retombe sur ses pieds si je puis dire et
que nous actifs on finance bien la
retraite de nos retraités
alors j'en ai dit peut-être une première
question luminaire parce que bon ça fait
plusieurs semaines voire plusieurs mois
qu'on dit les Français sont aussi le
recul de l'âge de la retraite ça ça
bouge pas et deux ça veut dire que le
président va devoir et ses ministres et
sa première ministre vont devoir faire
preuve de pédagogie c'est le chemin est
long quoi c'est ça pédagogie ou
conviction peut-être en fait les
pédagogie je pense que les Français ont
globalement compris que oui ça serait 65
ans bon en tout cas que globalement on
se dirigerait vers là mais déjà même
auprès du cœur de son électorat on peut
rappeler que ça avait été quasiment la
seule mesure qui avait identifiée dans
le cadre de la campagne électorale
présidentielle et que quand vous prenez
les principales motivations de vote
c'est des électeurs d'Emmanuel Macron de
premier tour la thématique de la
retraite n'arrive pas parmi les 5
premières motivations de vote de son
électorat alors que c'est ce qu'on a
retenu la troisième motivation de vote
de l'électorat et Jean-Luc Mélenchon et
la troisième motivation de vote de
l'électorat Marine Le Pen non pas pour
ce qui avait dit l'un ou l'autre mais
vraiment contre en rejet 65 ans ce qui
est extrêmement intéressant aussi c'est
qu'il tout un tas de mesures qui
viennent accompagner donc c'est pas
uniquement une mesure technique de
passage ou de changement d'age légal de
départ à la retraite mais il y a
également si je me trompe pas 1100 euros
en fait pour les nouveaux retraités une
réflexion une dont il a parlé hier sur
notamment la prise en compte des
carrières longues la pénibilité etc mais
que tout ceci notamment au regard de ce
qu'on disait tout à l'heure c'est que
l'hémisphère gauche n'est pas du tout
entendu de la part de l'opinion et donc
ils vont être focalisés sur la question
de du changement de l'âge légal de
départ à la retraite avec une tension
qui est absolument manifeste de la part
de nos compatriotes et pourtant vous
disiez pendant qu'on réécoutait Emmanuel
Macron qu'il a réutilisé un slow
quasiment un slogan
Ségolène Royal on peut se rappeler qu'en
2007 c'est que le Royal qui était
candidate à l'élection présidentielle
avait dit plus juste la France sera plus
forte et là en fait il a inversé le
propos mais en deux phrases il a dit
plus forte la France sera plus juste
c'est donc c'était globalement en fait
des termes un peu inversés aussi et qui
renvoie aussi un regard qui peut avoir
les gardes de l'action politique mais
qui est également entendu et qui
s'inscrivait globalement dans le message
qu'il voulait adresser hier qui
s'adressait à priori plus aux électeurs
et aux personnes qui situent à droite de
gauche quand on disait qu'en politique
et en communication recycle
éternellement les slogans le Macron
réformateur est-ce qu'il peut reculer
sur les retraites non donc il va y aller
il a pas le choix c'est obligé
effectivement il a donné aucun signe de
recul et par ailleurs je trouve que le
thème et là on voit effectivement un peu
cette tragédie pour Emmanuel Macron ce
thème lui donne l'occasion de venir sur
son cœur de cible hier soir il a
enclenché sur des questions assez
fondamentales il dit mais il faut qu'on
réfléchisse au plan de qualification
tout au long de la vie un point faible
la société française l'idée qu'on
n'apprend pas au bout d'un moment que
l'apprentissage s'arrête mais ça rien
n'est plus essentiel que d'enclencher
quelque chose d'important on a fait un
débat sur l'emploi des seniors ici même
c'est vraiment un des points central et
voilà un thème sur lequel on voit bien
qu'il pourrait assez facilement
capter l'attention de la CFD ce sont des
thèmes très CFDT qu'il a abordé à ce
moment-là de l'interview hier mais
effectivement ce qu'on retient il faut
qu'on bosse davantage et qu'on bosse
plus longtemps on voulait dire que la
voix des oppositions porte aussi bien
parce que ces messages là sont portés
par la nupesse et par le RN et avec un
propos également sur les régimes
spéciaux dont on n'avait pas forcément
entendu aborder jusqu'à présent qui a
été qui a été évoqué hier dans le cadre
de l'interview et on revient vous l'avez
un peu évoqué tout à l'heure claire
Chartier mais vous disiez il a pas parlé
aux français quand il est parce que
parce qu'en fait l'objectif c'est de
parler à Weller enfin politiquement
l'intervention d'hier
enfin je pense quand même que l'objectif
était partagé parce que à mon avis il
essayait quand même d'expliquer tout ce
qu'il faisait aux Français pour que au
syndicalistes
quand même auprès de la CDT parce que
ils ne veulent pas entendre parler de ce
reportage donc je ne vois pas trop ce
qu'ils vont discuter même si
effectivement ont été ébauchées et même
Eric worth te disait ça va être
difficile d'imposer une réforme des
retraites à des gens qui n'arrivent pas
à se chauffer en hiver donc ça va ça
s'avère quand même assez compliqué mais
effectivement il ne reste pas grand
chose en fait du Macron 2017 il reste
pas grand-chose aujourd'hui qu'est-ce
qui reste il reste effectivement ce
qu'on disait le travail le parti pris
l'entreprise donc s'il ne se tient pas
s'il ne tient pas fermement là-dessus ça
va complètement se déviter donc c'est
intéressant parce que c'est aujourd'hui
une journée d'action à l'appel de la de
la CGT qui passe totalement inaperçu
dans les médias je sais pas si vous en
avez entendu parler aujourd'hui moi j'ai
eu l'impression que ça n'existait pas
mais est-ce que les retraites peuvent
être quand même comme quand vous sondez
l'opinion le thème qui peut un peu
coaliser les colères on discute souvent
sur ce débat de entre lassitude et
colère comment dans quel état est
l'opinion publique française sur le
papier oui mais entre le papier et la
réalité un écart qui est un écart
manifeste le propre d'une crise c'est
que en fait a posteriori on arrive
toujours à très bien l'expliquer et a
priori bravo d'avoir cette humilité
parce qu'il faut savoir dire je ne sais
pas a priori
on peut l'annoncer comme on l'annonce
chaque rentrée comme étant une rentrée
sociale qui cette année et pas être
particulièrement difficile ou
particulièrement douloureux jusqu'à
présent la rentrée sociale n'a pas été
non plus très très très virulente ce qui
est jaune depuis oui
mais là en fait donc il y a des il y a
des préoccupations il y a des
préoccupations en matière de de pouvoir
d'achat et les préoccupations
d'anticipation d'ailleurs de dégradation
de leur de leur pouvoir d'achat et
concernant la question de la réforme des
retraites on est également face à des
Français qui sont un peu ennuyés
c'est-à-dire qu'ils sont vraiment
extrêmement opposés au fait de passer à
l'âge de leur traite à 65 ou 65 ans mais
jusqu'à présent qui ont du mal à pouvoir
trouver d'autres solutions ou des
solutions alternatives ils n'ont pas
envie de ça mais il n'arrive pas à
pouvoir avoir une petite idée de comment
on pourrait faire
et l'argument qui est martelé qui est de
plus en plus entendu à savoir il y a
aujourd'hui en fait une structure
générationnelle qui fait que ça impose
de travailler plus pour garder notre
système de retraite par répartition créé
en tout cas jusqu'à présent une forme de
tension d'un point de vue d'opinion
merci beaucoup merci à tous d'avoir
participé à ce premier débat